[Music]
in african countries poor living
conditions are endemic
and diseases such as malaria diabetes
and tb
are widespread healthcare facilities are
generally under resourced
and often decrepit and yet so far the
continent has avoided the worst of the
pandemic
there were fears that living conditions
in urban communities in south africa
and beyond would accelerate the spread
of the virus
but some experts are now asking what if
those same crowded conditions
also offer some extra protection against
covet 19.
[Music]
some scientists thought a youthful
population might be behind
africa's relatively low infection rates
but as the pandemic continues analysts
are more and more reluctant to put the
continent's successes
down to demographics some researchers
have also hypothesized that the presence
of certain parasites in the body are
contributing to higher survival rates
but they're still trying to unravel the
mystery
[Music]
africa has recorded a little over 1.4
million cases of coronavirus
that's less than a quarter figure of the
figure for the united states
alone almost half of the continents
confirmed cases
were in south africa but even there the
death rate
is surprisingly low and the country's
scientists are pushing to find a vaccine
the search for a life-saving covert 19
vaccine is back on in johannesburg
any any questions no does that sound
okay
today we'll also get you to sign um the
amendment
to make sure that you understand that
we've actually discussed
the study pause and the reviews and that
the study has started
again okay okay
oxford university partnered with south
african vaccinology experts in june
to begin producing a locally effective
serum to vaccinate against the
coronavirus
which was halted when a sister trial in
the united kingdom saw a participant
take ill
thank you you can put your boss back on
i'm just gonna yeah when i heard that
someone was sick
in england i was worried because i
didn't know
what to think because we were told about
the risks
involved with this vaccination trial
but after a few days i understood what
it was about
and i'm happy to continue with the trial
i didn't even notice it the first day oh
really
okay the efforts form part of emergency
measures to deal with the coronavirus
pandemic in the world's most unequal
society
it's very important for us to know that
these vaccines
are both safe and effective in a south
african
population who may differ greatly from
from populations in in
other parts of the world south africa
much like the rest of the continent
has not experienced the covert 19 death
rate seen in parts of the developed
world
this has baffled some experts as to how
a country with poor living conditions
a high burden of diabetes tuberculosis
and hiv aids
was not overwhelmed by the pandemic
south africa has a much younger
population than many european countries
and younger people are less severely
affected
than older people in addition about 40
percent of those young people we
estimate had asymptomatic infection
and that might be because they've been
exposed to other coronaviruses that
caused the common cold
earlier on as african traditional
medicine uses
indigenous communities have a simple
hypothesis
claiming south africa weathered the
covet 19 storm through the power of
traditional medicine that is widely used
throughout the country
for them the search for a modern vaccine
in africa is futile
and offensive
so we feel insulted that people who come
with methodologies from the west
could come and land in our shows and
want to think that we can just be
vaccinated
it's problematic without recognizing the
fact that the ancient systems of healing
that exist and resonate in our in our
midst
amid this opposition the vaccine trial
continues with fears a second wave of
covet 19 infections could arrive in
coming months
we need to try and diminish the impact
of covert both
from a health point of view but also
from a socio-economic
point of view and that can actually only
be done
if we have a suitable vaccine going
forward
only a few months old the vaccine trial
is expected to run
at least until the latter part of 2021
i'm really hopeful that by this time
next year we'll have a vaccine
available the studies are going well and
we should be able to achieve it
with almost 16 000 deaths and over 650
000 infections in south africa alone for
dr fairley and her team
the arrival of a vaccine can't come soon
enough
well coronavirus deaths across africa
are lower than scientists would have
expected especially when you consider
there may have been many more cases than
have so far been recorded
a number of reasons have been put
forward for that from africa's young
population to traditional medicines
but there is another more unusual
hypothesis
some scientists believe parasitic worms
could be protecting some africans from
the full effects
of covet 19. on this we can speak to dr
akim herrauf who is a parasitologist at
bonn university
thanks for joining us can you please
tell us what this hypothesis is all
about
yeah good afternoon we have been working
a long time on the immunology of uh
parasitic diseases and the host response
of the human
immune response particularly against
worms
and one of the dominant features is that
the worms
ensure their survival for 10 years and
longer in the body
by suppressing the immune response for
example take
river blindness which is a parasitic
warm disease that is
spread out through tropical africa with
about 40 million
people infected and here you have
a warm larvae in the skin amounting to
some hundreds per square millimeter yet
the immune response is so down
regulated that there is almost no
inflammation in the majority of people
and they sometimes don't even know they
have the disease
so we know also that there is a spill
over
of this immune response to other
immune responses for example negative is
that
some vaccines do not work as well as
they should and
this has also been very clearly aligned
to this immune suppression and the mode
of action is
more or less well established and the
hypothesis now
is that this overshooting immune
reaction that comes with severe
cobit 19 cases might be mitigated
because the people harbor worms and have
an immunosuppressed
general status
if this hypothesis does prove to be true
are there any implications for a
possible treatment for coronavirus
it has long been sought to sort of carve
out the
beneficial immune parts of the immune
response
of a parasite immunosuppressive mode
and avoid the the total parasitic
infection but this is very tricky you
have to imagine
that the parasite harbors about 10 000
different proteins
and even more other molecules that it
can play with in order to interact and
down regulate the immune system
and not to speak about the of the
infection and the locality and all these
things so it's very complicated and so
far
except for a few molecules that
for example have been shown to down
regulate
and now becomes very specific call like
receptors which
are sort of part of the immune in that
immune system also playing a very
important role in
septic infections that they can be
addressed by small molecules but they
are still
in the preclinical development so we are
not yet there and it would definitely
be longer than uh the perspectives for a
kobit 19 vaccine which
seems to be more or less around the
pronoun
okay so we won't be relying on the worms
just yet dr akim
hirao from bon university thanks a lot
for joining us
thank you very much and now it's the
part of the program where we pose one of
your questions to our science
correspondent
derek williams
if you inhale sarskov ii does the number
of viruses you inhale
make a difference in your symptoms
this is a really interesting question
because it touches on a recent comment
made by a top
american health official that
universally
masking up might be more effective than
a vaccine
at protecting us from covet 19.
the idea behind that claim is that
although
masks don't prevent people from being
exposed to the virus entirely
by limiting exposure they could help
reduce
the number of people who developed
severe cases
of the disease and the theoretical
equation is that
light exposure leads to more
asymptomatic cases and
and there's some evidence um to back
that idea up
from settings like cruise ships and and
meat packing plants where
where people who were required to wear
masks during covet 19 outbreaks
on average got less severe forms of the
disease
now the exact amount of virus that it
takes to make someone
really sick is a kind of a slippery
concept called
the infectious dose or viral dose and
and there's no way to really tell for
sure whether
a higher infectious dose causes more
severe symptoms or not
um at least not in humans that's because
if you really want to test the idea
you're going to run into a major ethical
problem you'd have to
intentionally infect people with varying
amounts of the virus and
and basically wait to see what happens
next
but we have carried out studies like
this in animals
for example hamsters and they do indeed
show
that there appears to be a correlation
between
being exposed to more saurus cove to
and disease severity which is not really
a surprise
but of course other factors like like
age
and general health also play big roles
in outcomes
you